نفذت القوات البحريه في القوات المسلحه
اليمنيه عمليه عسكريه استهدفت سفينه شحن
عسكريه امريكيه اوشن جاز في خليج عدن
اعلنت البحريه الامريكيه مقتل اثنين من
افراد قواتها الخاصه في خليج ضربات
استباقيه ضد قواعد جاهزه لاطلاق الصواريخ
الحوثيون يدخلون اسلحه جديده في معركه
البحر الاحمر فيما الحكومه اليمنيه
المقيمه في الرياض تضعو لتكثيف الضربات ضد
الحوثييين الاتحاد الاوروبي يتجه لمعاقبه
تلب بسبب سياسه النتنياهو مصر تمد نازحي
القطاع بالمياه مخترقه الحدود والسيسي
يصرح ما حدش يجرب مصر ويهدد اشقائها اقمار
صناعيه تظهر تراجعا كبيرا للاليات
والمعدات العبريه في القطاع ورسميا
السعوديه تضع شروطها النهائيه للتطبيع
خيبه امل جديده للاداره الامريكيه ولكبار
ضباط تلبيب في حرب القطاع وبوتين يتحضر
لزياره كوريا الشماليه فما هو المغزى
بينما موسكو تعمل على مصادره
288 مليار دولار لاصول غربيه وقرارات
امريكيه تثير المخاوف لدى الحكومه
الاوكرانيه ورئيس استخبارات نظام يدلي
بتصريح صادم ويكشف
المستور الحوثيون لا
يتوقفون في البحر الاحمر لا يتوقف انصار
الله الحوثيين عن ضرب كل ما يتجه الى تل
ابيب فقد نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن
مسؤولين امريكيين انهم لا يتوقعون ان
تستمر العمليه في اليمن لسنوات لكنهم
يعترفون بانه من غير الواضح متى
ستتاهل للحوثيين بشكل كافن فيما نقلت
بوليتيكو عن معلومات استخباراتيه امريكيه
ان الحوثيين يسعون للحصول على اسلحه
ايرانيه لتكثيف هجماتهم ومهاجمه القوات
الغربيه في المنطقه الرد الغربي جاء بلسان
يمني هذه المره حيث حذر مجلس القياده
الرئاسي اليمني المقيم في الرياض الحوثيين
من مغبه تصعيدهم الحربي على مختلف الجبهات
ومواصله استثمار قضيه القطاع العادله
وانهاء معاناه الشعب اليمني كما رحب
المجلس بقرار تصنيف الحوثيين كمنظمه
ارهابيه عالميه متطلعا الى مزيد من
العقوبات ضد حكومه صنعاء بالعوده الى تل
ابيب فقد افادت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال ان
مسؤولين في اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بداوا يقلصون توقعاتهم للحرب
العبريه من تدمير الفصائل بالكامل الى
اضعاف تهديدها الامني ونقلت الصحيفه عن
مسؤولين عبريين قولهم انه و على الرغم من
الحمله الجويه والبريه في القطاع فان هدف
تدمير الفصائل لم يتحقق واضافت نقلا عن
تقديرات استخباراتيه امريكيه ان ان
الفصائل لا تزال تمتلك ذخائر تكفي لضرب
تلبيب عده اشهر واليكم المصدر افادت صحيفه
وول ستريت جورنال ان مسؤولون ان مسؤولين
في اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن بداوا
يقلصون توقعاتهم للحرب الاسرائيليه من
تدمير حماس بالكامل الى اضعاف تهديدها
الامني وكانت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز كشفت عن
وجود حاله من الاحباط وسط بعض كبار ضباط
الجيش العبري لطول العمليات العسكريه في
القطاع وعدم تحقيق النتائج المرجوه منها
ونقلت الصحيفه عن بعض كبار الضباط القول
انه من الصعب تحقيق هدفي القضاء على
الفصائل وتحرير المحتجزين في الوقت نفسه
ليخرج وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان ال سعود ويؤكد بان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لن تتمكن من تطبيع علاقاتها مع
تلبيب حتى يتم التوصل الى حل طويل الامد
للقضيه الفلسطينيه وخلال مقابله مع شبكه
سي ان ان شار الوزير السعودي الى ان حل
القضيه هو مفتاح الاستقرار والازدهار
لمنطقه الشرق الاوسط باكملها بما في ذلك
التلبيب وهو المصدر
[موسيقى]
يتحدث هنا كشف موقع اكسس الاخباري ان
اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تعتزم
السع الى تطبيع العلاقات بين تل ابيب
والسعوديه بشرط موافقه تل ابيب على اقامه
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله قبل ذلك كان
النتنياهو اعلن انه رفض شروطا قدمتها
الفصائل لانهاء الحرب واطلاق سراح الرهائن
والتي تتضمن الانسحاب البري الكامل وترك
الفصائل على راس السلطه في القطاع وفي
تغريده له على حسابه على موقع اكس زعم
نتنياهو ان اصراره هو الذي حال دون قيام
دوله فلسطينيه لسنوات طويله والتي كانت
ستشكل خطرا وجوديا على تلبيب وفق تعبيره
وكانت نقلت صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز عن
مسؤولين اوروبيين قوله من الاتحاد
الاوروبي يحث اعضاءه على معاقبه تل ابيب
اذا واصل نتنياهو رفض قيام دوله فلسطينيه
واضاف المسؤولون الاوروبيون ان الاقتراح
مؤشر على غضب اعضاء الاتحاد بسبب رفض تل
ابيب خطه حل الدولتين وفق تعبيرهم وقالت
مصادر اوروبيه بان وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي يبحثون عواقب قد تواجهها ابيب
اذا رفضت حل الدولتين ولنتصور
[موسيقى]
فيما قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو وترش على منصه اكس ان رفض
الاعتراف بحال الدولتين وحق الفلسطينيين
في اقامه دولتهم امر غير مقبول واكد انه
ينبغي ان يعترف الجميع بحق الشعب
الفلسطيني في بناء دولته الخاصه وميدانيا
اظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه عرضتها قناه
الجزيره ترج جعا كبيرا لعدد الاليات
العبريه المتمركزه على شريط القطاع
الساحلي وذلك بعد اعلان جيش تل ابيب عن
سحب فرقه كامله منتصف الشهر الحالي من
جهته اعلن الهلال الاحمر عنه اصول 105
شاحنات محمله بمساعده انسانيه عبر معبار
كرم ابو سالب للقطاع لننتقل الى مصر حيث
كانت منظمه حقوقيه مصريه كشفت في تقرير
لها ان الحكومه المصريه قامت بامداد
النازحين من القطاع في المنطقه الحدوديه
مع مصر بالمياه عبر خطوط بلاستيكيه تم
تمريرها من السياج الحدودي على ساحل البحر
مرورا بمحور فيلادلفيا من جهته قال الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ان بلاده لن
تسمح بتهديد الصومالي وامنها في رساله
فسرتها وسائل اعلام محليه بانها رساله الى
اثيوبيا واوضح السيسي مش بنهدد حد ومش
هنسمح لحد يهدد الصومال ما حدش يجرب مصر
ويهدد اشقائها خاصه لو طلبوا اننا نبقى
موجودين معهم وقالت الرئاسه الصوماليه في
بيان لها ان م قديش لن تسمح بسيطره دول
اخرى بما في ذلك اثيوبيا على اي جزء من
اراضي البحر الاحمر مؤكده ان الصومال
يتمتع بميزه ان يكون له حصه جغرافيه كبيره
في البحر
الاحمر كياف ترتعد
خوفا خوف اوكراني شديد يزداد حده مع مرور
الايام فقد اثارت تصريحات الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب فيما يتعلق بانهاء
الحرب في اوكران مخاوف لد كياف من ان
تتخلل قراراته تنازلات لا يمكن لاوكرانيا
القبول بها ياتي ذلك فيما امتنع الكونغرس
عن تجديد حزمه المساعدات لكيف مما يطرح
تساؤلات حول قدره اوكرانيا على الاستمرار
في الحرب من دون دعم امريكا هنا افادت
صحيفه نيويورك بوست الامريكيه ان رفض
الرئيس فلاديمير زيلينسكي التفاوض مع
روسيا ادى الى عرقله فرص اوكرانيا في تلق
التمويل الغربي من جهته قال رئيس
الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه كيريل
بودان اوف ان هذا العام سيكون صعبا على
اوكرانيا والقوات الاوكرانيه وفي مقابله
مع صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز بريطانيه اضاف
ان من يعتبر ان كل شيء سيكون على ما يرام
في اوكرانيا سيكون مخطئا في سياق اخر
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين اعرب عن استعداده لزياره
بيون يانج في وقت مبكر وان بيون يانج
مستعده لتحيه اقرب اصدقاء الشعب الكوري
باكبر قدر من الاخلاص وذلك بعد يومين من
عوده وزير خارج كوريا الشماليه جوي سون
هوي من رحله الى موسكو وفقا لوكاله انباء
يون هاب الكوريه فما الذي يخطط له بوتين
من هذه الزياره هنا النداء الاخير النيتو
يستعد لمواجهه روسيا في حرب يوم القيامه
نشوء حرب عالميه ثالثه لم يعد احتمالا
مستبعدا فنتو يؤمن باقترابها حد اليقين
وبدا يحث المدنيين والحكومه على الاستعداد
لصراع سيغير حياتهم فالى ماسا يؤول هذا
الوضع برايكم لنضع المصدر
امامكم الحرب الشامله تقرع طبولها حشد غير
مسبوق للقوات الروسيه والنيتو يستعد لاكبر
مناوره عسكريه بمشاركه 90 الف جندي من
الدول الاعضاء ويحذر المدنيين والحكومات
للاستعداد لصراع سيغير حياتهم في الحرب
الاقتصاديه سيخسر الغرب اصولا ثماره بما
لا يقل عن
288 مليار دولار ان اقدم على مصادره اصول
روسيه مجمده من اجل المساعده في اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا لترد موسكو بعد ذلك على
هذه الخطوه وفق ما اوردت وكاله الاعلام
الروسيه وعلى الارض اعلن رئيس جمهوريه
الشيشان الروسيه رمضان قاديروف ارسال
مقاتلين من الفوج ال94 من لواء العمليات
الخاصه التابع للحرس الروسي الى منطقه
العمليات العسكريه الخاصه وفي الحصيله
يوميه افادت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بمقتل
نحو 570 عسكريا اوكرانيا بعمليات للقوات
المسلحه الروسيه في نطاق العمليات
العسكريه الخاصه خلال
[موسيقى]
يوم